[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Siebers ihnen
allen guten Abend it's the most German
crisis ever schreibt das aus Amerika
stammende Nachrichtenportal politico die
deutscheste aller Krisen und meint damit
eine Regierung die nicht mehr weiß wie
sie all ihre Vorhaben finanzieren soll
weil ihr das Verfassungsgericht die
ursprünglichen Pläne dazu um die Ohren
gehauen hat bislang habe sich der
deutsche Eifer auf maßvolle Schulden zu
pochen gegen die Südeuropäer gerichtet
jetzt gegen sich selbst wir erleben ein
Land das dringend nach Geld sucht und
nach Halt und Richtung also nach einer
Regierungserklärung im besten Sinne und
wir erleben das was der Bundeskanzler
daraus macht heute im Deutschen
Bundestag Lars
bonssack vielleicht hatte der Kanzler am
Morgen noch gehofft dass seine
Regierungserklärung ein Befreiungsschlag
werden würde für die Ampelkoalition
immerhin ringt er sich zu Beginn das
Eingeständnis ab dass das Urteil des
Verfassungsgerichts die Arbeit der Ampel
deutlich erschwere klar ist dieses
Urteil schafft eine neue Realität für
die Bundesregierung und für alle
gegenwär und die zukünftigen Regierung
im Bund und in den Ländern eine Realität
die es allerdings schwieriger macht
wichtige und weithin geteilte Ziele für
unser Land zu erreichen doch der Kanzler
wird selten konkret in seiner Rede es
ist eine Regierungserklärung ohne
Erklärung keine Übernahme von
Verantwortung für die Klatsche aus
karlshur kein Wort des Bedauerns kein
Ansatz wie der Haushalt 2024 aussehen
könnte nur das Versprechen in Lehr Raum
dass der Staat seine Bürger nicht
alleine lasse in ihrem Alltag hier und
heute ändert das Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgericht nichts völlig
unabhängig davon ob sie Kindergeld oder
BFK bekommen eine Rente oder Wohngeld
der Kläger von Karls R wird zum Ankläger
im Bundestag Oppositionschef März wirft
der Regierung Manipulation der
Verfassung vor attackiert den Kanzler
persönlich und spricht ihm die Eignung
fürs Amt
ab sie sind ein klemtner der macht ihnen
fehlt jede Vorstellung davon wie dieses
Land sich in den nächsten Jahren
weiterentwickeln soll sie haben keine
Ahnung von dem was da in den nächsten
Jahren auf sie und auf uns zukommt März
macht deutlich dass die Union an der
Schuldenbremse festhalten wolle und muss
sich vorwerfen lassen dass seine Truppen
doch schon längst nicht mehr beisammen
sein und ich will erinnern an H wü
an
Reiser Hasel Michael kretm alle diese
unionsministerpräsidenten haben bereits
öffentlich erklärt dass sie bereit sind
die Schuldenbremse zu schleifen der
einzige der einzige meine Damen und
Herren aus der Union der in dieser Woche
die Schuldenbremse noch nicht in Frage
gestellt hat ist Markus Söder aber meine
Damen und Herren es ist ja auch erst
Dienstag liebe Kollegen Kollegen es
riecht schon nach Wahlkampf im Plenum es
wird häufig laut die Abrechnung Reg ist
scharf auch an den Rändern des
demokratischen Spektrums die Bürger
haben in dieser Lage nicht auf ihre
Regierungserklärung gewartet her Scholz
sondern auf ihre
Rücktrittserklärung die Realität ist
doch Deutschland hat offensichtlich ein
Fachkräfteproblem mindestens bei
Finanzministern überzeugen konnte Scholz
wenn überhaupt die een le
dieen oppos haben das übrige getan um
die Reihen in der Ampel wenigstens für
heute zu schließen sollte der Kanzler
aber auf die Union gehofft haben um die
Krise zu lösen dann dürfte er enttäuscht
worden
sein Christian Kastrop ist Professor für
öffentliche Finanzen und Fiskalregeln an
der FU Berlin wir merken schon genau das
Thema um das es geht und er war vor
allem 2009 als einer der wichtigsten
Beamten im Finanzministerium damals
Vater der Schuldenbremse Herr Professor
guten Abend guten Abend Herr Sivas ist
ihnen der Begriff heute ein bisschen
unangenehm oder sehen Sie die
Schuldenbremse weiterhin als ihr
wichtigstes Werk na ja sie ist schon ein
sehr wichtiges Werk sie hat damals eine
alte Regel abgelöst das war eine reine
boto invvestitionsregel und ich glaube
das ist ein echter Fortschritt wie
würden Sie denn sagen brauchen wir diese
Schuldenregel diese Schuldenbremse heute
auch noch oder muss die tatsächlich
angepasst werden und oder kann sie weg
also meiner Meinung nach kann sie nicht
weg wir brauchen sie immer noch es war
von Anfang an eine Regel an wo die
öffentliche Nachhaltigkeit
im Vordergrund stand und dafür brauchen
wir sie auch weiterhin aber das heißt
schon auch dass man nach 14 Jahren
Praxis drüber nachdenken kann sie hier
und da anzupassen und was würden Sie da
vorschlagen was wären denn die Punkte an
dem die Schuldenregel die Schuldenbremse
tatsächlich angepasst werden müsste na
ja zum einen könnte man sich überlegen
ob dieser berühmte Spielraum von
0,35 äh strukturelles Defizit der ist
damals politisch verhandelt worden 2009
den könnte man natürlich auch verändern
das wäre eine Möglichkeit und dann
entstehen natürlich auch für die
Transformation notwendige Spielräume
würden Sie sagen es gibt gute und es
gibt schlechte
Staatsausgaben ich würde schon sagen
dass man das tun sollte also gut und
schlecht ist vielleicht sehr weitgehend
aber es gibt welche die einfach
produktivere Ausgaben sind die
zukunftsorientierte Ausgaben sind und
ich glaube das ist das was auch um uns
herum international in Europa geschieht
und da könnte man mehr tun international
sie sprechen es gerade an wir sind ja
mit unserer Wirtschaft nicht auf so
einer einsamen Insel alleine
Großbritannien hat gerade am Wochenende
ein neues milliardenprogramm an
Subventionen für die Wirtschaft
aufgelegt die USA bieten Firmen
Milliarden die dort investieren und wir
in Deutschland haben die Schuldenbremse
kann denn das funktionieren ja sicher
kann das funktionieren die
Schuldenbremse ist ja eben keine
Investitionsbremse sie versucht nur den
die Schuldenaufnahme so zu kontrollieren
dass sie eben nicht übermäßig wird na ja
aber wenn ich sie kurz unterbrechen darf
aktuell scheint es ja doch eine
Investitionsbremse zu sein denn die
Regierung sucht ja gerade händeringend
nach den Milliarden die jetzt fehlen ja
nun gut da hat's Probleme mit dem
Bundesverfassungsgericht gegeben wegen
der Jährlichkeit dieser Mittel die man
so ein bisschen hin und her geschoben
hat das ist die eine Sache aber die
andere Sache ist natürlich die dass die
Schuldenbremse und das tut die Regierung
ja jetzt auch man kann sie noch mal
aussetzen für ein Jahr man kann das auch
noch für ein weiteres Jahr tun also ist
nicht so dass wir allein wegen der
Schuldenbremse jetzt diese großen
investitionsaufgaben
transformationsaufgaben nicht angehen
können wie können denn andere Länder
einfach sagen wir geben Milliarden wir
geben Milliarden an Subventionen raus
was machen die anders als
wir zunächst mal haben die natürlich
eine andere politische Ökonomie in ihren
Ländern es gibt z.B in Großbritannien
ist in der Regel eine
Einparteienregierung die kann relativ
gut durchregieren die brauchen nicht
unbedingt eine Schuldenregel wir wie wir
die brauchen vielleicht auch unser etwas
komplexeres politisches System und USA
ist ein ähnlicher Fall da hat man sehr
große Veränderung gesehen die haben ihre
Steuern sehr stark erhöht sie haben aber
auch in der nächsten Regierungszeit sie
dann wieder sehr stark gesenkt und das
gleiche gilt auch für die statsausgaben
ich denke mal in Deutschland in seinem
föderalen System und für viele andere
europäische Staaten ist eigentlich eine
kluge Schuldenregel schon ganz gut gut
und die macht eigentlich auch nichts
kaputt auf der einen Seite haben wir die
Schuldenbremse auf der anderen Seite
haben wir Schlagworte wie Bazooka Wums
doppelwurms
Sondervermögen sie haben es gerade auch
schon kurz angesprochen jetzt wird diese
Schuldenbremse ja zum vierten Mal
infolge ausgesetzt geht da nicht auch
der Sinn von dem ganzen Konstrukt
verloren nicht unbedingt also man muss
schon vorsichtig sein man darf das nicht
auf ewig tun aber wir haben natürlich
auch ganz besondere Herausforderung
gehabt in den letzten Jahren äh ich
erinnere an die militärische
Interventionen in der Ukraine Russlands
Angriff ich erinnere jetzt an neue un
neue Herde von Unsicherheit in der Welt
also ich denke schon dass eine
Schuldenbremse dann auch mal einige Zeit
hintereinander ausgesetzt werden darf ja
aber mit Vorsicht und mit jeweils
politischer Entscheidung also noch mal
zusammengefasst was würden Sie jetzt
sagen wie muss es jetzt weitergehen da
klafft auf der einen Seite ein riesiges
Milliardenloch im Haushalt auf der
anderen Seite habe ich sie ja so
verstanden dass weiter Investitionen
dringend nötig sind auch in die
Wirtschaft also was wäre jetzt
zusammengefasst ihr Tipp an die aktuelle
Regierung also mein Tipp ist die
Schuldenbremse auszunutzen auch in ihren
Spielräumen aber der zweite Tipp wäre
der man muss jetzt und vielleicht auch
sogar über die aktuelle
Regierungskoalition hinaus einfach
drüber nachdenken welche Staatsausgaben
brauchen wir auch in den nächsten Jahren
auch dauerhaft was bedeutet das an Stats
für die Staatseinnahmen was bedeutet das
für die Sub
man darf sich nicht nur ein Instrument
rauspicken man muss jetzt wirklich
überlegen wie bauen wir die
staatsauusgaben die Staatseinnahmen
vielleicht ein bisschen um und da sollte
man einfach ohne Scheuklappen und
politische
voreinstellungswinkel einfach mal dran
gehen sagt der Vater der Schuldenbremse
Professor Christian Kastrop von der FU
Berlin ganz herzlichen Dank dass Sie
heute an diesem besonderen Tag bei uns
waren und ich wünsche ihn von uns allen
hier herzlichen Glückwunsch herzlichen
Dank Herr siers und ihnen auch noch noch
einen schönen Abend der Experte hat
seine Geburtstagsfeier für uns
unterbrochen und wir haben das Gespräch
deshalb vor einer Stunde
aufgezeichnet dass der NATO
Generalsekretär sein Bündnis heute vor
einer Ukraine Müdigkeit warnen muss sagt
ja im Grunde schon alles heute Tag 1 des
NATO außenministertreffens in Brüssel
und die Schlagworte dort
Standhaftigkeit Durchhaltevermögen
angesichts des nahostkriegs der gerade
die Schlagzeilen bestimmt
und angesichts der Tatsache dass in der
Ukraine militärisch aktuell ein
tödliches Pad herrscht wir müssen also
heute gucken auf den Stand und auf den
Zustand des Bündnisses und das machen
wir mit unserem natoorrespondenten
Florian Neuhann guten Abend Florian nach
Brüssel welches Rezept hat die NATO denn
jetzt gefunden gegen diese
ukrainemüdigkeit tja man sucht ein
solches Rezept natürlich vor allem auch
von Seiten der Ukraine ich glaub man
konnte heute mal wieder in Brüssel zwei
Strategien beobachten die eine war
sozusagen Augen und Ohren
zuzuhalten zu sagen es gebe gar keine
Kriegsmüdigkeit das sagte etwa der EU
Außenbeauftragte Josep Borel ich halte
das für eine eher gewagte These wenn man
man anschaut dass etwa auch die
europäische munitionshilfe stockt dass
Europa seine Versprechen nicht erfüllen
kann oder auch dass US-amerikanische
Hilfe gerade eben nicht weiter
beschlossen werden kann und dann kommt
Strategie Nummer 2 ins Spiel das ist zu
setzen auf drastische Warnungen auf
Appelle dass wenn Russland eben
teilweise Erfolg habe in der Ukraine
dann auch die Sicherheit des
europäischen natogebiets in Gefahr sei
und diese Warnungen die werden durchaus
erhört es wird ja weiter geholfen aber
man muss sagen dass aktuelle Maß an
Hilfe das reicht eben nicht aus damit
die Ukraine diesen Krieg in kurzer Zeit
gewinnen kann ja und dann Florian gab's
internen natoärger weil Schweden immer
noch nicht Mitglied der NATO werden kann
eigentlich sollte Schwedens Aufnahme
heute gefeiert werden woran hängt das
denn jetzt immer
noch na es fehlt noch das endgültige ok
die Ratifizierung von zwei natoländern
von der Türkei und in deren Windschatten
auch aus Ungarn und da war der Ärger
heute in den Reihen der NATO so groß wie
ich das hier noch selten erlebt habe am
deutlichsten war wohl die französische
Außenministerin die sagte hier vor den
Kameras da stehe jetzt auch die
Glaubwürdigkeit der NATO auf dem Spiel
am Ende aber hat die NATO relativ wenig
Druckmittel in der Hand es gibt ja auch
andere Themenbereiche etwa das Beispiel
Flüchtlinge wo man selbst etwas etwas
von der Türkei will insofern das ganze
zeigt noch einmal wenig ein wenig die
Schwäche auch der NATO sie braucht eben
Einstimmigkeit und wenn ein Land oder
auch zwei blockieren dann ist diese
Allianz
handlungsunfähig die Nato und eine ganze
Reihe ihrer Probleme Florian neuh live
aus Brüssel herzlichen
Dank und Han hat jetzt hier den ersten
Blick auf die Nachrichten und beginnt an
einer rund
1300 km langen Grenze in Europas Norden
ja es geht um Finnland das jetzt seinen
letzten noch geöffneten Grenzübergang zu
Russland für den Personenverkehr
geschlossen hat das verkündete der
finnische Ministerpräsident orpo die
Regierung reagiert damit auf eine
zunehmende Zahl von Migranten aus dem
Nahen Osten die in den vergangenen
Monaten ohne gültige Papiere über
Russland nach Finnland eingereist waren
das neue natoitglied wirft dem Kremmel
vor die Asylbewerber gezielt nach
Finnland zu
lenken Deutschland erlebt aufgrund des
Klimawandels immer häufiger Hitzewellen
und hat sich bereits deutlich erwärmt zu
diesem Ergebnis kommt der
klimamonitoringbericht den
Bundesumweltministerin Lempke
vorgestellt hat die
Durchschnittstemperatur habe sich seit
1881 um 1,7° erhöht das sei stärker als
im Rest der Welt mit 1,2° Grad Ergebnis
der Studie ist zudem dass Deutschland zu
den Regionen mit dem höchsten
Wasserverlust weltweit
gehört das
verläumdungsverfahren gegen den Musiker
Gil Ofarim vor dem Landgericht Leipzig
ist nach einem Geständnis des Sängers
eingestellt worden Ofarim hatte im
Oktober 2021 in einem Video in den
sozialen Netzwerken behauptet er sei von
einem Hotelmitarbeiter antisemitisch
beleidigt worden heute räumte er ein
nicht die Wahrheit gesagt zu haben und
entschuldigte sich bei dem Mann das
Verfahren wird gegen eine Geldauflage
von 10 000 €
eingestellt bundesweit blieben heute
viele Bildungseinrichtungen insbesondere
Schulen und Kitas geschlossen etwa 20
000 Mitarbeitende beteiligten sich an
einem Warnstreik der Gewerkschaften
werdi und
geww wie hier in Leipzig gingen unter
anderen Lehrkräfte und Kita Beschäftigte
auf die Straße sie fordern 10,5% mehr
Lohn mindest jedoch 500 € mehr im Monat
mit dem Streiktag wollen die
Gewerkschaften Druck auf die
Tarifverhandlungen im öffentlichen
Dienst der Länder
machen unser Staat hat allen Eltern ein
klares Versprechen gemacht jedes Kind in
Deutschland kann ab seinem ersten
Geburtstag einen kitaapatz bekommen
darauf gibt es sogar einen
Rechtsanspruch dieses Versprechen hat
der Staat bislang immer gebrochen und er
tut es weiterhin der Rechtsanspruch wird
für 100000
nicht erfüllt zeigt eine neue Studie
danach hängt viel vom eigenen Wohnort ab
es gibt große Unterschiede innerhalb
Deutschlands und es gibt viel zu tun
Alexander
rötch er hat gekämpft um ein kitaapatz
und Glück gehabt Patrick Schober bringt
Töchterchen Chloe jeden Morgen in die
Düsseldorfer Kita die zornkönige es war
für alle Eltern hier in CS Ringen um die
raren Plätze ohne Kita geht nicht wenn
man arbeitet doch viele Eltern gehen
leer
aus vorher sich anfangt zu kümmern kaum
ist das Kind da muss man eigentlich
schon gucken dass man irgendwo auf einer
Liste steht und dort reinkommt alle die
jetzt im Moment bei uns suchen sagen sie
haben riesen Probleme haben halt
irgendwie tausende Bewerbung
losgeschickt und tingeln jetzt von Kita
zu Kita wir mussten halbes J suchen hier
in GI ein kitait Navigator da kann man
10 Kitas eintragen sich aussuchen ja und
die Kappert man dann zu Beginn alle ab
mehr als 400.000 Plätze fehlen
bundesweit Kita Leiter Julio bon erlebt
die Not jeden Tag wenn besorgte Eltern
auf der Matte stehen wir haben knapp 500
Anfragen bei neuen Plätzen die wir
überhaupt zu vergeben haben wir haben
jeden Tag um die 10 Eltern die hier
anrufen die noch verzweifelten
kitaitapatz suchen also auch aktuell das
heißt also auch während des laufenden
Kita Jahres die man immer wieder
vertrösten muss die irgendwie total
verzweifelt sind die Studie zeigt in
Ostdeutschland ist die Personaldecke
besonders dünn im Westen der Mangel an
kitaapätzen schlimmer 90% aller Plätze
fehlen in den alten Bundesländern Kinder
und Beruf lassen sich so kaum
vereinbaren insbesondere die Frauen
trifft es dann immer wieder die gar
nicht berufstätig sein können oder nur
sehr eingeschränkt es bedeutet aber auch
zu sehen dass die Kinder nicht das an
bildungsunterstützung bekommen können
außerhalb der Familie wie das eigentlich
gewünscht ist Bund und Länder haben viel
in den Ausbau investiert doch der Bedarf
wächst schneller als die Zahl der Plätze
das
Bundesfamilienministerium der Bund
unterstützt die Länder zudem seit
einigen Jahren mit zusätzlichen Mitteln
in Milliardenhöhe zu jetzt hat der Bund
den Ländern mit dem Kita qualitätsgesetz
insgesamt rund 4 Milliarden Euro für
2023 und 2024 für Maßnahmen zuur
Qualitätsentwicklung
bereitgestellt aber woher soll das
Personal kommen kchef Julio bason wartet
bei Stellenausschreibungen schon mal
Wochen auf eine Bewerbung der Beruf muss
einfach attraktiver werden das ist so
dass man das ist einfach eine hohe
Belastung in der Kita psychisch aber
auch physisch gerade im U3 Bereich und
da muss ich sowohl an der Bezahlung was
tun und dadurch würde natürlich auch
einfach der der Personalschlüssel dann
hoffentlich irgendwann steigen doch das
wird dauern die Ausbildung von
Erzieherin und Erziehern kostet Zeit die
Kitas werden noch Jahre mit
Personalmangel kämpfen sol lang steht
der Rechtsanspruch auf ein kitaitplatz
für viele Familien nur auf dem
Papier in Nahost ein Blick nach vorn
Waffenruhe Freilassung der Geiseln
vielleicht gibt es eine Verlängerung der
Verlängerung hinter den Kulissen sind
diverse Vermittler im hektischen Einsatz
die Chefs von CIA und mossat sollen sich
in Qatar
austauschen dann auch der weitere Blick
nach vorn und der ist durchaus
sorgenvoll die USA haben ihren
israelischen Verbündeten heute klar
machen wollen dass jeder weitere
armeeeinsatz im Süden von Gaza so
strukturiert sein muss dass nicht wieder
hunderttausende fliehen müssen für die
die geflohen sind aus dem Norden und wir
reden von über einer Million Menschen
ist die Rückkehr alles andere als sicher
für die Angehörigen der von Hamas
verschleppten Geiseln die bislang
vergeblich auf den erlösenden Anruf
warten dass Ihre Liebsten freigelassen
werden es es ein Leben von Minute zu
Minute jeder weitere Blick nach vorn
getrübt von Sorge und Bangen Dominik
lmeister der kleine quier Bibers ist die
jüngste Geisel der Hamas die meisten
anderen Kinder wurden inzwischen
freigelassen während Kier und sein vier
Jahre alter Bruder ar iterin in der
Gewalt der Hamas
sind die Angehörigen und Freunde der
Geiseln am Abend in telaviv auch
Verwandte der bibas sind gekommen Sie
bitten die Weltöffentlichkeit zu helfen
die Familie nach Hause zu
bringen morgen ist der letzte Tag der
Feuerpause Arielle und sind die jüngsten
Jungen die immer noch als Geisel
gehalten werden und noch nicht
freelassen
wden warum wir ihre Rückkehr fordern wir
haben die ganze Familie versammelt um
für sie zu schreien weil sie es nicht
können das Bild ging um die Welt eine
Mutter die ihre beiden Kinder an sich
drückt während sie von Hamas Terroristen
entführt werden die Familie will dass
wir diese Bilder zeigen gerade weil sie
so erschreckend sind die Eltern Jaden
und Shiri mit ihren beiden Kindern dem
VI Jahre alten Ariel und dem 10 Monate
alten
BB en am Kopf verletzt während ihr auf
einem Motorrad von der Hamas entführt
wird bis jetzt haben wir keine
Informationen wir wissen nicht ob sie
sie füttern ob sich als Baby gut
entwickelt wer umarmt sie wer kümmert
sich um sie wenn sie weinen wir wissen
nicht ob sie überhaupt zusammen sind die
Mutter das Baby sein Bruder Ariel es ist
ein
Albtraum das ist israelische Militär
vermutet Hamas habe die Familie an eine
andere palästinensische
Terrororganisation übergeben noch sind
neun Kinder Geiseln im
Gazastreifen jeden Abend gibt es eine
Liste mit den Namen der von Hamas
freigelassenen Geiseln das Schicksal der
Familie bibas und die bange Frage wann
stehen Sie auf der Liste und wann kommt
die Familie
frei ja das ist wirklich ein Albtraum so
jetzt noch mal du Hanna hier und eine
Meldung die wirklich aufhuchen lässt es
geht darum dass Stromnetzbetreiber ab
Januar bei einer Überlastung des Netzes
die Stromzufuhr drosseln dürfen und zwar
für neue Wärmepumpen und Ladestationen
von E-Autos die in Deutschland in
Privathaushalten ja immer mehr werden
und das wirft Fragen auf Stephanie
Barrett was bedeutet das konkret für
alle die eine Ladestation oder eine
Wärmepumpe besitzen oder installieren
wollen ja bedeutet ganz konkret dass
Netzbetreiber vom 1 Januar an
übergangsweise durchaus weniger Strom
für Wärmepumpen und E-Autos liefern
können wenn die Netzstabilität gefährdet
ist die Regel ist nötig geworden weil
die Stromnetze im Moment einfach noch
nicht stabil genug sind für die große
Masse an Wärmepumpen und
ladeeinrichtungen ist das Stromnetz in
einem Gebiet überlastet weil etwa sehr
viele E-Autos gleichzeitig laden oder
sämtliche Wärmepumpen unter Vollast
laufen dann können Netzbetreiber
notfalls die Stromzufuhr für den
Zeitraum der Netzüberlastung drosseln es
muss dabei aber immer eine
Mindestleistung zur Verfügung stehen so
dass Wärmepumpen weiterlaufen können
wenn sie dabei auch etwas weniger stark
wärmen und E-Autos können wenn auch im
Schneckentempo weiterhin Laden ganz
wichtig der reguläre Haushaltsstrom ist
nicht betroffen und laut
Bundesnetzagentur sollen derartige
Eingriffe auch nur im Ausnahmefall
vorkommen gibt es dann noch irgendwelche
Entschädigungen oder Vorteile für die
Nutzer also Verbrauchern winken im
Gegenzug wohl Rabatte laut Bundes
Netzagentur bis zu 190 € pro Jahr und
schnellere Genehmigungen für die
Installation Ihrer Ladepunkte und
Solardächer denn derzeit zögern ja
Netzbetreiber oft aus Sorge vor einer
möglichen Überlastung der Leitungen nun
können Sie die Netzstabilität der selbst
steuern sie müssen aber auch den Ausbau
der Stromnetze zügig vorantreiben vielen
Dank Stefanie für diese
Einordnungen der französische
Reifenhersteller michel hat angekündigt
in Deutschland mehr als 1500 stell
abzubauen und hier zu Lande künftig
keine lkwreifen mehr herzustellen bis
Ende 2025 soll die Produktion an den
Standorten Karlsruhe Trier und Homburg
eingestellt werden Gründe seinen
steigende Produktionskosten und die
Konkurrenz aus Niedriglohnländern
über zwei Wochen waren sie
eingeschlossen 41 Arbeiter in einem
eingestürzten Tunnel im Norden Indiens
jetzt konnten alle befreit werden durch
ein 90 cm breites rettungsrohr wurden
sie herausgezogen das Loch dafür hatten
Helfer zum Teil per Hand gegraben weil
die großen bergungsmaschinen zuletzt
versagt hatten nach einem Erdrutsch
waren am 12 November Teile des
Autobahntunnels eingestürzt allen
Arbeitern soll es den Umständen
entsprechend gut
gehen ja und es gibt sie doch eine
deutsche
Fußballnationalmannschaft die Erfolg hat
die U17 Auswahl des DFBs hat das Finale
der Weltmeisterschaft in Indonesien
erreicht mit einem 4:2 im fmeter
Schießen gegen
Argentinien das Ende einer emotionalen
Achterbahnfahrt auf dem Weg ins Finale
nach Führung und Rückstand in der ersten
Halbzeit gleich der Dortmunder
paris-brunner in der zweiten Hälfte zum
2:2 aus in der 69 Minute sorgt der
Hoffenheimer Max Mörstedt dann per Kopf
für die erneute Führung der DFB Auswahl
doch der Schock in der Nachspielzeit
Argentinien nutzt seine wohl letzte
Chance zum Ausgleich das 3:3
durchto es geht direkt ins Meter
Schießen dort pariert Konstantin Heide
aus Unterhaching gleich die ersten
beiden 11er der Argentinier und Paris
Brunner verwandelt den entscheidenden
Schuss vom Punkt für Deutschland Team
hat das ganze einfach gezeigt dass wir
so eine Mentalität haben dass wir irwi
immer zurückkommen können und ja
unfassbar stolz einfach aufs Team
Deutschland gegen Frankreich heißt es
nun im wmfale am
Samstag sehr sehenswert was jetzt kommt
es geht um Lösungen aus der Wissenschaft
am Ende von
2023 dem Jahr der Zukunftsfragen
Energiewende Klimawandel künstliche
Intelligenz alles in Les Kosmos jetzt
direkt nach uns hier im
ZDF ja und gegen 0:45 Uhr gibt's dann
unser heute journal Update mit
Christopher wermann und von uns allen
hier auch den Kolleginnen und Kollegen
hinter den Kameras ein angenehmen Abend
tschüss
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend erstmals wird es auf
der bevorstehenden Weltklimakonferenz in
Dubai einen Gesundheitstag geben denn
die globale Erhitzung beeinträchtigt die
menschliche Gesundheit steigen die
Temperaturen und Feuchtigkeit weiter an
sowie es eine neue wissenschaftliche
Studie aus den USA zeigt wird die Gefahr
größer das Mensch überhitzen besonders
gefährdet sind Afrika Indien aber auch
der Nahe Osten abhängig davon wie weit
global die Mitteltemperatur ansteigt
extreme Unterschiede sind zwischen 1,5 2
und letztlich 3° zu finden aber warum
ist die Feuchtigkeit für uns Menschen so
ein großes Problem bei Hitze produziert
der Körper Schweiß um abzukühlen damit
die Feuchtigkeit verdunsten kann muss
die Umgebungsluft relativ trocken sein
ist die Luft aber sehr warm und und
gleichzeitig feucht ist dieser Effekt
eingeschränkt und der Körper überhitzt
ein Hitzeschock tritt ein der zum Tod
führen kann laut Studie sind bei einer
Erwärmung von 3° bis Ende des
Jahrhunderts Milliarden Menschen
gefährdet und so eng hängen
klimagesundheit und Wetter miteinander
zusammen aktuell gibt es Schnee von
Norden her der dehnt sich aus in die
Mitte und auch im Süden schneit es
Temperaturen gehen zurück auf -10° im
Osten und -1 gerad im Westen überall
frostig kalt morgen ziehen die
Schneeschauer weiter Richtung Südosten
dabei kann sich wieder eine Schneedecke
ausbilden im Süden bleibt es sonnig ja
und die Temperaturen steigen auf -2 bis
5° und auch die nächsten Tage weiterhin
teilswinterlich mit Schnee und Eis und
damit einen schönen Abend